so so in the morning we we heard some
the basics about really rooted and
stable point all males and now we can
start talking about some of the things
she can prove using stable polynomials
and in particular the very exciting work
by Markus Gilman and Sarah stava it's
really connected the worlds of stable
point normals and combinatorics and
computer science and really generated
all this excitement that we are
witnessing here now so before we get
there let me let me discuss this in a
slightly more general way we're going to
talk about certain ways to prove the
existence of some objects which don't
really tell you what exactly the object
is and these are the proofs that we call
non constructive or non algorithmic and
let me do a very quick high-level
overview of the kinds of methods that we
that we know in combinatorial which are
'disformed they can be broadly
categorized as follows we have the
probabilistic method which has been very
successful which is essentially you
perform some random experiment generally
some generate some random object and
then you prove using some probabilistic
tools that the object has the properties
that you desire and there have been many
applications of this I can't even start
to discuss them but the important thing
is that we have probabilistic tools
which are useful here and immediately
this kind of proof raises the question
whether you can actually find the object
algorithmically over you whether you can
somehow describe it explicitly so this
is an interesting question which will
also come up here another broad category
of methods is a topological one which
maybe has fewer applications in terms of
how many ways we have but it's also very
interesting conceptually maybe the most
famous example of topological proof in
in Computer Sciences the existence of
Nash equilibria which is implied by
brower's fixed-point theorem essentially
you can formulate your problem as a
topological problem and the existence of
some fixed point or some topological
property implies the solution to your
problem so this is another another broad
category of non constructive proves and
the third category could be described as
algebraic methods one such method is the
combinatorial notions art and the more
recent one is what we are talking about
here both polynomials so what these
methods share is that you represent your
problem as some statement about the
roots of certain polynomials and argue
about the roots either some counting
argument about how many roots there
might be or something about the location
of the roots and and these kinds of
arguments can yield some very
interesting results so let's call these
methods algebraic famous examples of
results proving prove proved by
algebraic methods are the finite field
kakeya problem and most relevance to
this program the existence of Ramanujan
graphs and the Caddy's and singer
problem
the algorithmic question is interesting
in all of these cases for the
probabilistic method I think by now it's
fair to say that almost all applications
of the probabilistic method have been
made algorithmic at least using
randomized algorithms so we should be
careful what we mean by constructive in
some areas of mathematics constructive
might mean just having any finite time
procedure that constructs the object so
here we are mostly talking from the
point of view computer science for young
efficient polynomial time algorithms but
there's still a distinction between
deterministic and there and another
question that comes up is whether you
can actually tell that your output is
correct you might have a randomized
procedure which produces what you want
with high probability but maybe it's
actually hard to verify what it produced
is correct so we have to be careful
about all these details when you talk
about something being constructive or
not the topological method seems
generally difficult to make algorithmic
one famous example is again the Nash
equilibrium problem where we have a
proof of hardness in some technical
sense that is hard to find a Nash
equilibrium although it always exists it
is PPID hard to find it and now even in
proximate sense it's hard to find it so
topological methods generally seem non
algorithmic the algebraic methods are
interesting so the problems that we will
talk about here particularly Ramanujan
graphs and the Catalan singer problem
were both very interesting questions and
the question for Ramanujan graphs has
been resolved in the positive so there
is an efficient algorithm to define term
illusion graphs which was done by
Michael Owen for the Karason singer
problem this still remains a major open
question
so now let's postpone all these
algorithmic questions that's not the
point of my lecture here and let's start
talking about Ramanujan graphs
what are Ramanujan graphs in some sense
they're the best possible expanders so
the best possible expanders in the
spectral sense so the regular graph we
can look at the eigenvalues there's
always the top eigen value of D if the
graph is bipartite yosef minus D and
then where are the other eigen values
that will determine the expansion
properties of your graph so let's call
GN and D lambda expander if it has n
vertices it's deep regular and all the
eigen values except the D and possibly
minus D are in the interval minus lambda
lambda the smaller we make lambda the
better expander we get so what is the
best lambda that you can hope for this
is given by the Allen poppin a theorem
generally you cannot hope for lambda
smaller than 2 square root particular
graphs for small graphs you can have
lambda smaller than this but you cannot
have an infinite family for arbitrarily
large and of graphs where lambda is
strictly below two square roots
this is the optimal bound that you can
hope for the question is are there such
infinite families of your house and they
exist and the first constructions of
such graphs you've probably heard about
them they're very famous results and
also very difficult results so these
were two independent works by Lubitz key
Phillips and sonic & Margolis and they
both constructed infinite families of
Ramanuja graphs where all the
non-trivial eigenvalues are bounded by 2
square root D minus 1 and the degree is
in the form some prime plus 1 this comes
out of some algebraic construction
Cayley graph of some private groups
defined by defined in terms of matrices
and the analysis is complicated the
analysis uses algebra number theory it's
sophisticated the name of Ramanujan
comes up because the Ramanujan
conjectures and number theory sting and
comes up in the proof of
where this was extended to prime powers
past one but not all possible degree so
so a natural question here is is this
really a number theoretic problem is
there something special about prime or
is there a simpler way to do it you know
what is what is happening with Ramanujan
graphs this was essentially resolved as
at least in the bipartite case by
groundbreaking work talked about here by
Markus Beeman and Sarah stava
so there was already a procedure which
was proposed earlier which works as
follows which looks like a reasonable
approach so start with some small
expander let's say complete graph and
repeatedly perform the following
operations let's call this to lift
operation so you duplicate each vertex
and you also duplicate each edge for
each edge you produce two new edges well
you can do it in two different ways so
let's call this either two parallel
edges or two crossing edges for these
two duplicated for disease the vertices
became pairs and the edge which was
between them became two parallel edges
which means u 0 B 0 and u 1 V 1 randomly
we decide to do either that or the other
option which is to crossing edges u 0 V
1 u 1 V 0 so so that's a random
operation which we can apply to a graph
we obtain a graph of the same degree and
the number of vertices goes up my factor
of 2 you
it looks reasonable somehow this might
mix well here because we do things
random it's a reasonable proposition
below and lineal came up with this
procedure also proved that it works
quite well and they prove that lambda is
bounded by roughly square root
the lock cubed D so it's almost the
right bound
except there's this poly log D this was
the state-of-the-art until beautiful
proof this actually works perfectly in
the bipartite case so if you start with
the bipartite Ramanujan graphs you
always have these eigenvalues T and
minus D they stay there now all the
other pagan values are going to be
bounded and absolute value by two square
root D - the best possible bound you get
an infinite family of graphs like this
beautiful result what else wanted to say
at this point so this can be viewed as a
randomized algorithm theorem claims that
this succeeds with positive probability
the probability might be very small so
this is not an algorithmic proof CS
point of view at least later there was
follow-up work by Marcos permanent
service tada
and building up on that work Michael
Cohen showed an efficient algorithm to
construct our monographs so that's very
interesting
maybe Nikhil will discuss it later or it
will come up
certainly later so this result has been
made algorithmic
but let's talk now about the existential
result
so we have this procedure which blows up
the graph and there's something to the
edges and we need to track the
eigenvalues of the adjacency matrix so
how do these eigenvalues change under
the tulip operation let's see what
happens so let's call this blown up
graph G s2
let's encode the the random choices that
we have let's encode them by the vector
plus minus ones where we have a plus
minus one on each edge of the original
graph and plus one means that we will
replace the edge by two parallel edges
and minus one means that we replace it
by two crossing edges the operation so
so now given this vector s what happens
to the eigenvalues it's complicated at
first but actually it's pretty simple so
the eigenvalues of the new graph are
exactly all all the eigenvalues of the
previous graph they just stay there plus
a new set of eigenvalues which are
exactly the eigenvalues of the sign
adjacency matrix the same adjacency
matrix but we put a plus 1 or minus 1
for each edge and this is exactly the
sign encoding what happens to that edge
in the blow-up operation this is pretty
easy to see because you can take any
eigenvector of the original graph and
either you you just duplicate the
coordinates you put the same value on
each of the new vertices or you add a
minus sign to one of the two quotes so
this produces two vectors which are
actually orthogonal and when you look at
the eigenvalues these will just inherit
the eigenvalues of the previous graph
and these eigenvectors these will be the
eigenvectors of the matrix a s assigned
so so these will produce the new eigen
that so we assume inductively that we
started with a Ramanujan graph and so
far things have been fine so so the
eigenvalues of the previous graph are
fine by assumption but the goal is to
see what is happening with the new
eigenvalues the eigenvalues of the
signed adjacent solutions that's the
goal any questions pretty clear so for
every edge this is this is on the
vertices these are coordinates of the
eigenvector on the vertices so I will
just copy them and for all other copies
so I take an eigenvector from the
previous graph I will copy it to the new
graph but then for each vertex which
became two copies I will flip the sign
on one of the two copies and it's easy
to see that when you apply the signed
adjacency matrix to it this will be an
eigenvector
sorry this would be the eigenvector of
the signed adjacency matrix and when you
arrange the signs like this and the new
graph then it'll be an eigenvector of
the adjacency matrix of the blown-up
graph yes
what we're view is if you restrict
coupon functions on every vertex to get
two copies are two orthogonal subspaces
and yeah we get
so we get two and eigenvectors and two
and so yeah so it boils down to
analyzing the eigenvalues of this
assigned Jason
so so here are two classical results
which are very helpful and suggestive of
what should happen somehow so the first
the result is that when you look at the
sign adjacency matrix you look at the
characteristic polynomial so that's the
point Omiya lose roots are exactly what
we care about the eigenvalues but now
let's take the expectation over all the
possible signings so we have if you have
M edges we have 2 to the M possible
signings of the edges the characteristic
polynomial depends on the signing so
let's take the expected characteristic
polynomial over this random sign theorem
says that that happens to be exactly the
matching polynomial that we talked about
earlier that's interesting it's actually
the matching defect polynomial which
which I defined earlier that that's nice
and we also have a theorem of Hyman and
liebe which talks about the roots of the
matching point on and it tells us that
for the irregular graph the maximum root
of this matching polynomial is
guaranteed to be at most 2 square root
deep minus 1 so it looks like there's
something happening here this cannot be
a coincidence this is exactly the bow
that you would like to obtain and this
says that the expected characteristic
polynomial has roots bounded by the
bound that we want exactly that the
expression that we want so I wonder what
what niccola at all were thinking when
they saw this but it's like this must
work right but something is not
something doesn't add up so what doesn't
add up
the roots of this expected polynomial in
general don't have anything to do with
the roots of these individual
polynomials which are sitting in here
in general if you take some family of
polynomials and just average them take
their average and you say something
about the roots of this average point
Armijo it might not have much to do with
the roots of these individual point
ovals in general this is not true
there's something very special about
this family of polynomials which
actually makes that true which makes it
and that's the magic of interlacing
polynomials so so what are interlacing
polynomials this is a picture similar to
what I showed in the first lecture
there's a little difference here but
here we have two polynomials of the same
degree so for two polynomials of degree
n we say that they have a common
interlacing if we can place these
markers on the real line gamma 0 gamma 1
and so on such that the eye roots of the
two polynomials respectively alpha I and
beta I are the eye throats of Earth
largest roots of F and G are sitting in
the same interval gamma a gamma hi - so
when you look at the picture between
every pair of consecutive consecutive
black points you see red the root and
blue root somehow the two polynomials
are oscillating up and down in a
consistent manner you could say that's
what we call having a common interlace
so here is a very nice alternative
equivalent way to express this property
polynomials to monic polynomials which
means the leading coefficients might
have a common interlacing if and only if
every convex combination of these two
polynomials is also real written it
shows what is happening here the blue
polynomial and the red polynomial have a
common interlacing and the claim is that
this is the same property as every
possible convex combination of the two
being also real rooted so let's see why
this is true
this has two directions one direction
let's assume that the convex
combinations are real rooted okay let's
assume in addition that F and G don't
share any roots this is a technical
assumption we can do it without loss of
generality because if they share some
roots you can just take out those roots
and remember in you can break down the
polynomial is a product of factors and
these point owners would share some X
minus lambda J factors so just take them
out so now think about what happens when
we move continuously from one plano meal
to the other one move T from zero
towards one and we can track the
polynomials of this intermediate point
oniel HT as they move on the real line
now I say it's useful to have the fact
which was an exercise after the first
lecture which was that if you change the
coefficients of the polynomial
continuously the roots move continuously
in the complex plane well now we assume
in addition that all these intermediate
polynomials are really rooted so
actually they move the roots they move
continuously on the real line not
allowed to escape to the complex plane
so as you move T
each route let's say that the I throat J
throat will move from lambda J of zero
to lambda J of we have these intervals
lambda J of zero lambda J of one the
claim here is that the interiors of
these intervals actually have to be
disjoint overlap also you cannot have a
larger interval containing a smaller one
or in other words inside this interval
lambda J 0 and lambda J 1 you cannot
have another root of one of these two
polynomials and why well that's that's
exactly because we are not allowed to
have shared roots or because we actually
eliminated them this is what would
happen if you had another root in this
interval let's say lambda K of 1 which
would mean that would be a root of F
lambda K of 1 if it was in side this
open interval well then it would mean
that for one thing it's a root of F but
also it's a root of this intermediate
point on no HT for some T strictly
between 0 and 1 that would imply because
this is a non-trivial convex combination
it will also need to be a root of G so
it would actually have to be a root of
both F and G but we took out all the
shared roots so this cannot happen
so this is a contradiction so actually
you cannot have another route
it can never happen that these intervals
overlap the interiors overlap they might
touch at the endpoints that might happen
but these in these intervals are
disjoint except for the endpoints so
they are ordered on the real line just
like in the picture and this means that
and you have a common interlace again we
can put some black points to separate
this interval the black point could be
it on the endpoint of the interval it
could coincide with the route that's so
long but we can find this common
interlace actually in this proof I mean
the starting point lambda J of zero is
simply a simply root of G I guess you
can also prove that the root is actually
not allowed to leave that interval I
didn't even need that explicitly in this
proof but it's also true that as the
root moves from one point but from F to
G it cannot leave the interval and come
back because again that would mean that
let's say the root of G was identical to
a root of one of the polynomials HT
somewhere in the middle so that also
cannot happen so yeah
doesn't have to be it doesn't have to be
one of them the extreme points out yeah
yeah I think it might be a monotonic
right it should move monotonically but
I'm not I don't need it here but I think
like it cannot go like this
then I think you could find two
non-trivial convex combinations where
the roots coincide and that would also
imply that there's a shared alright the
other implication is actually one of the
exercises so let me skip it
the corollary here which would will be
very important if F and G have a common
interlacing you look at one of these
intermediate polynomials HT may be the
average of the two let's say it has a
maximum root mu the picture suggests
this maximum the root of the gray
polynomial is actually between the
maximum roots of the blue and red so one
of the two either blue or red must have
a maximum root which is at most
mu normally you can also say that you
can actually design the common
interlacing to B such that gamma 0 and
gamma 1 are exactly these two maximum
the roots the maximum root of the Blue
Point normal and the maxing root of the
red polynomial and because the gray
polynomial is consistent with the same
interlacing its maximum root is
somewhere in between it will actually
use this conversely we will know
something about the maximum root of the
gray polynomial and on this picture at
least it's obvious that one of the two
maximum roots of F or of G must be at
most mu they cannot be both above
because the maximum root of the gray
polynomial is between them so this will
be very important
make sense we already said we already
proved that F and G have a common
interlacing if and only if all the
convex combinations are real rooted and
from this proof it also follows that the
great polynomials follow they are
consistent with the same interlacing
points so the great polynomial actually
must be such that it's maximum root is
between gamma 0 and gamma 1 the picture
is suggestive but this is also this is a
critical argument in in the proof and
with this property we can formulate the
method the method of interlacing
polynomials at a high level is the
following so we have we have some family
of polynomials let's say index by s s
consists of M parameters they just post
minus 1 it works even more generally but
let's say the choices are just binary
plus minus 1 so one polynomial is the
expectation over all s just the expected
polynomial over all that's the
polynomial that we know something about
you recall that happens to be the
matching polynomial
then we have these intermediate
polynomials where we have fixed the
number of choices we have fixed let's
say the first K choices as one through
SK are already fixed to be plus and
minus ones and we take the expectation
only over the remaining choices
so now the argument of Marcos permanent
service table is as follows follows
start with F and P set we already know
that its maximum root is bounded by what
we want bounded by 2 square root D minus
1 because it's a matching polynomial and
we know that that's the case so the
maximum root is well behaved now we have
two choices for s1 and we are deciding
to set a swan to be either plus 1 or
minus 1 and by the argument on the
previous slide the polynomial F empty
set is a convex combination of the two
polynomials where s 1 equals plus 1 and
s 1 equals minus 1 so it's maximum the
root is somewhere in between the maximum
roots of these two guys for at least one
of these two choices the answer must be
yes the maximum root is still bounded by
two square root
so this is you know it's in some sense
an algorithm except this is not
implementable in polynomial time like
this but you can make this sequence of
choices you check these two the answer
is yes here so set s1 to be equal to +1
then ask about the next variable s2
should it be truly plus 1 or minus 1
again check the max in the root one of
them must be at most two square root you
can continue like this what is important
when does this work it works if at every
step the two relevant polynomials have a
common interlacing we still haven't
proved that part and we did we don't
know that so if it's true that every
step we have two polynomials which have
a common interlacing then we can invoke
the argument about the maximum root and
we can argue that one of them must have
a bounded
so what remains what remains is to be
implemented because it's hard to figure
out the roots of all this yeah so so how
would you how would we compute the roots
there has been an effort to do that I
think Shawn so for one thing these
polynomials are their averages over
exponentially many polynomials and then
you have to compute their Max and Ruth
so that's not easy
you can approximate the maximum roots in
certain ways and you can get some
approximate results we'll also build up
yeah so you can you can analyze this and
try on has a paper with who are the
authors so they have a paper where they
do this very carefully using smart
methods using chebyshev polynomials and
they achieve a running time of 2 to the
cube root of n so you can do something
non-trivial but it's still that method
is far from
maybe the immediate thing is the reason
you can't complete them exactly it is
because the last coefficient to the
problem so like the polynomial you
cannot compute the coefficients yeah
right right the methods that they use
actually don't require all the
coefficients right it's only some
sequence of coefficients but yeah we
don't have these polynomials explicitly
available that's the first reason
until you either clear the coins Medford
doesn't make this right right very good
yeah so it was a follow up follow up
paper of the same authors where they did
the whole thing a little bit differently
and they obtained a stronger result that
not only you have infinite families for
every degree D but you actually have a
ram anujan graph for every D and every n
so that was paper number four I think
and roughly speaking it was that method
which Michael Pollan
made
all right so this is the high-level
description of the method and what
remains to be proved is that at every
step the two relevant polynomials have a
common interlacing as you recall we had
a lemma saying that one way to prove
that to polynomials have a common
interlacing that you prove instead that
every convex combination of the two
polynomials is also real rooted so so
MSS actually proved the whole thing in
one one elegant theorem which says that
all these mixed characteristic
polynomials are in fact really rooted so
what exactly is happening here so we had
these polynomials X sub s where s is a
plus minus 1 vector which corresponds to
the way we do the blow up operation so
now let's take a convex combination of
these actually many characteristic
polynomials where we do the convex
combination under a product distribution
so you can imagine then you set each si
to be either plus or minus 1 with
certain probabilities its probability is
just interpolate between plus and minus
1 so we can generalize the notion of X
sub s to X sub certain numbers between
plus and minus 1 and we get this mixed
characteristic polynomial the
polynomials which appear in the
interlacing oilless method are
polynomials of this form we already
fixed the sides up to a certain point we
fix the first K signs and the remaining
ones are random they're half half half
well I shifted it oh yeah actually this
should be zero
yes I should in the range after so zero
means that it's an unbiased choice and
in fact you can plug in for SK plus one
you can plug in anything between plus
and minus 1 which will get you all these
convex combinations of the two relevant
ponen so all the great polynomials there
of this form so this master theorem
master stability statement tells you
that all these polynomials and many
others are actually okay so what the
proof is actually something even a
little bit more general it's the
following kind of statement
so take independently random vectors
each of them can have some distribution
let's say support it on two choices but
that's not even very important what we
need here is random vectors each of
which has two possible two possible
choices and they're independent that's
important and we look at this expected
characteristic polynomial of the matrix
which is formatted direct products of
these random vectors so these are random
rank one matrices and that that seems to
be the important element here that we
have a matrix which is built up by
random rank one update the randomness is
independent between these successive
choices and each of them is just a rank
one update that to be the core of this
method and MSS true that any polynomial
in this form is actually real
so we can complain the previous theorem
from this one quite easily if you
remember the relevant matrix in the
previous theorem was the signed
adjacency matrix so what is the signed
adjacency matrix there's pluses and Plus
Ones and minus ones for edges it has
zero on the diagonal so that's not very
convenient just actually convenient to
shifted by D times the identity you
create degrees on the diagonal and you
make it look like the laplacian then you
can express the matrix as a summation of
these rank one matrices so for each edge
you put down a certain vector which is
the indicator of one vertex plus they're
the appropriate sign times the indicator
vector of the other vertex and then the
same vector transpose so this will
create exactly the four tuple of entries
a plus 1 minus 1 minus 1 plus 1 or
depending on what the sign of that edge
was you will produce that 2x2 matrix
that you want and if you add them up
over all edges that's exactly the matrix
Express
di + s can be expressed
the choices here are just plus/minus one
independently this theorem is much more
so here's what you can say actually more
generally you can say or any collection
of independently random vectors you know
the maximum route or a bound upper bound
on the maximum route of this mixed
characteristic polynomial matrix
obtained by random summation of random
rank one matrices there exist
deterministic choices for these random
vectors for each of them there exist a
choice such that when you look at this
characteristic polynomial this is an
actual characteristic polynomial of the
maximum root of this is also upper
bounded by one the one the same bound
the proof is exactly what I described
the sequence of choices were in each
step we look at the point Amiens where
some of these choices have been already
fixed the remaining ones are still
random we look at the expected
characteristic polynomials over the
remaining random choices and again we
have the property that the two relevant
polynomials where we fix the next choice
to be either this or that assuming that
we have two choices for each it works
actually more generally but if you have
two choices for each vector then the two
relevant polynomials have a common
interlacing and therefore for one of
them the maximum root must be upper
bounded by the upper bound for the
convex combination so the upper bound
propagates and you can one by one fix
these choices until you have
deterministic choices for all M vectors
and the maximum root of this
characteristic polynomial is still upper
bounded by the same thing so this is a
very general procedure which is also
useful for
the cat is sensing a problem all right I
think that's all my slides we hand out
the we will take a little break
[Applause]